welcome everyone good afternoon my name
is Alyssa Strom I'm the executive
director of the pan-canadian AI strategy
at c4 and also the associate vice
president research and it's my pleasure
to welcome you all today to CFR's
webinar on science is the exit strategy
this is a new series of webinars that
we're offering to share with our
community research that's going on by c4
researchers fellows candidacy for AI
chairs in Canada and around the world to
share how science and science-based
decision-making can be used in this
being used by governments to help us
think about how we can reopen the
economy in the wake of koban 19 if
you're not familiar with us CFR is a
Canadian based global charitable
organization and we can be extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing society and humanity
like many others across the board CFR
has pivoted quickly to take action on
coab in 19 and we've done a lot of work
in the last nine weeks to mobilize
researchers across Canada and around the
world to help them and support them
advance research on kovat what I'd like
to do today to kick off is introduce you
to two researchers that we look at see
for me
marzia kissimmee is a candidacy for AI
chair at the vector Institute and
assistant professor at the University of
Toronto where she also holds the Canada
Research Chair her work focuses on
applying machine learning to understand
and improve health
Joseph Paul Cohen is a postdoctoral
fellow with yoshua bengio at miele in
Montreal and at the University of
Montreal his work examines the
applications of AI in medicine with
respect to computer vision genomics
clinical data etc so Marcy and Joseph
have a new collaboration that has
emerged as a result of Copan 19 and them
thinking collaboratively about how they
can work together to address some of
these issues their projects will use AI
to develop approaches to understanding
code 19 based on chest x-rays and so
we're going to explore and other types
of medical imaging so we're going to
explore their project a little bit more
before we begin though just a few sort
of housekeeping issues this session
today will last for approximately
thirty minutes and I'm gonna sort of
kick off the conversation but then we'll
open up the floor for questions so we
would love for the audience to send in
your questions please use the Q&A
function and not the chat function
because we'll be sort of monitoring your
questions that come in through QA and
we'll make sure that we save plenty of
time for those questions and lastly I
just want to let everybody know that
this session is being recorded so if you
want to go back and look at it later or
send it along to your friends we'll have
it up on the Seafarer websites
early next week okay so let's begin
marzia and Joseph thank you for joining
us today to share your work and to be
part of this conversation let's start
joseph by talking a little bit about the
work that you did last year you built a
platform called Chester Chester sort of
ironically named an AI chest x-ray
radiology assistant tool that your team
developed and now you're pivoting and
thinking about how to apply some of that
work and the knowledge and tools that
you created towards coda 19 and so the
first step in your project with Mercia
is to build a public datasets of chest
x-ray CT images maybe other medical
images as well and so how are you guys
going about doing that what are the
steps you're taking and what are some of
the challenges that you're facing yeah
so uh initially we had this Chester
control and it already predicted
pneumonia given theta that existed
before from like the NIH MIT Stanford
and we wanted to say wanted to see does
this work on the co-payment pneumonia
cases is it able to offer an assistance
there and we looked around for what data
to try this on we couldn't find any and
we contacted a bunch of groups and it
seems very difficult to get data from
Hospital groups they're all they're also
very busy and hospitals that aren't busy
don't have any data yet because it
didn't have any data at that time it was
really difficult to get a handle on all
this data and it seems like the the
infrastructure and the hospitals was not
you know able to get us this data there
was no infrastructure in place to allow
researchers access to data as its as
it's happening right so this was
unfortunate
for us there but we found that journals
journal publications did have these
images in them
researchers were publishing like one or
two patients at a time in these
publications and then publishing them
that these high-resolution are sent kind
of high-resolution digital images on the
journal webpages of like radiology in
The Lancet right so in these in these
online publications we can access a
digital version that's it's actually
pretty high resolution compared to what
these models were trained on because we
would resize them to be pretty small
images it's like 224 by 224 resolution
images and the images on these websites
were a thousands by thousands right so
so we had like a sufficient resolution
there so we just started aggregating
these images into a dataset we could
work with by manually going to each
webpage downloading the image and then
reading the doctor reading the the
publication and finding the different
kind of clinical outcomes and the
different attributes about these
patients that were already published
there and this was really good for us
because the the ethics and consent were
already taken care of before this paper
was published right so that made it very
easy to work with us and inside the
ethical framework of the University of
Montreal because it's this is it's
already public and it's already at all
this consent on we can we can use it so
we could get going right at the gate
with all these images right so this
allowed us to start building up this
data set which is now we now have
hundreds of frontal chest x-rays from
from different patients right with
multiple time points world I guess -
yeah all over the way which is a good
way to validate these models because we
don't want to just have one hospital
they could have a an artifact that makes
it just work there but not other places
so we can really test tools this way
which has have been often how this this
data set has now been used by few groups
where they have their own internal data
set that they make and then when they
actually go to validate their model but
they do it on an internal data set to
really prove it or work because they can
have a balanced court that that's like
nice and randomly sampled but then they
can publicly use the data that we've put
together to to
demonstrated their models working right
this has been good and the beyond
publications were also looking at these
repositories that exist there's a euro
rad system which has been phenomenal as
a resource because their licensing is
very clear for us to use for research so
these different repositories that have
been put up that are are the kind of
silos themselves of this de saw these
livid just xperia
pieces right so they're not only do they
have just the x-rays they have CT slices
some of them have CTS like full CT
volumes so this is this this mass of
data that's tucked in all these
different systems all over the world and
and where we've been slowly puttin it
together into this data set and then
from the small data set we can can start
training these models so it sounds like
it's a very labor intensive efforts just
to even build the datasets in order to
be able to build the models and then go
on further and do research yeah it's
it's very hard to build automatic
scrapers we've had some some some
automation in in this we just got some
good results on our rad automatic
scraper so we we can scrape a bunch of
the detailed like that the the images we
can get them properly scraped with some
basic metadata but clinical outcomes
really hard to scrape from from natural
text that really ologists our writing
because you don't know if it says that
they tested for kovat and it was
negative or that they tested for
kovaydin it was positive right so that
the way it's worded can be just wild so
the best thing is to just have a human
reader so we've been doing that we have
dedicated students and like people
looking at these things and I've spent a
lot of time staring at these reports and
learning a lot about really guy you
really learn more about the disease by
reading a clean up a bunch of case notes
from doctors all over the world which
scared me a lot so just reading these
these cases are very sometimes it makes
a little bit more we all right great
okay so Maurizio I know that a key
objective of your project is to develop
some new machine learning algorithm
in order to be able to analyze these
machine these medical images that you're
aggregating across many many different
sources and so what like why and how is
that challenging what are some of the
challenges that you face
and like particularly from the fact that
these images are being compiled from so
many different sources and different
modalities in different languages may be
the case notes are in different
languages what are some of the
challenges that you have in actually
developing the AI tools once you've got
the data set together I think there are
a couple of things that make this very
challenging I think that the the first
thing to sort of keep in mind is we know
from work at nerves one of the large
machine learning conferences this past
year in December of 2019 that medical
image statistics don't follow natural
image statistics right so one of the
reasons that convolutional neural
networks are so efficient doing object
detection or classification or any of
the other many tasks that they they work
fantastically well on is because there
are these natural image statistics and
there are things that you can assume in
many cases about this modality right so
if two things are close in pixel space
right there either close in real life or
there's a border there right and those
kinds of assumptions don't work in you
know imaging modalities in the same way
right because it's not actually just a
natural image and so we know that there
are differences in how you may want to
fine-tune or take pre trained deep
neural networks and apply them to
medical imaging so that's that's its own
challenge and its own right there's also
a lot of you know uncertainty about
differences in you know severity of
cases and also labels for cases right so
one of the projects that one of the
postdocs in my group was looking at
she's looking at these labels that are
shared and in some cases not shared
between large chest x-ray imaging
datasets so these are data sets that are
by MIT by Stanford by the NIH and they
have some overlap in some of the
clinical labels that are assigned to the
images but it's not complete so some
places will label for you know a
particular condition and your Mathare
acts and others won't and this also
reflects differences in what those
actual care centers tend to specialize
in and the populations that they see in
general so those I think those are very
challenging because again when we
develop models in the natural world for
things like you know object detection we
know object detection is important
because humans do it it's a task that
humans do and we know that a dog is the
dog is a dog right we can argue about
what breed of dog and how old the dog is
but we all agree that this is a dog
right and it you could take an untrained
human not a specialist not somebody who
has gone to medical school for a decade
and every untrained human will agree
that this is this is a dog right but you
can have two expert radiologists who
have gone to school for decades and they
will disagree about the label that
should be assigned to this image so this
is also incredibly challenging for
machine learning models to operate under
and then finally one of the things
that's really challenging specifically
in this setting is that this is a novel
condition and that's something that
we're trying to wrap our heads around in
terms of how to do what it's called phew
shot meaning I see a few examples and
then I'm quickly able to generalize or
zero shot meaning I've not seen any
examples of this particular condition
but I'm able to detect it as a new
condition and these are specific regimes
in machine learning but they're often
when you when you use these specific
regimes often it's in very controlled
environments where you you promise that
you'll only show the algorithm five
classes during its training and it's
learning phases phase and then when you
show it new things you'll show it only
new things but none of you won't
evaluate it on the old things that it
might have
forgotten right and this is not and so
many of the evaluations that are present
in the sort of larger learning scenarios
don't apply here because we don't want
to show a model many examples of a
pneumothorax and you know hernia all
these different things a fracture and
then show it some kovat examples and
then have it forget well what is a
fracture look like I don't remember
additionally we have these multiple
labels right when you have one x-ray
image you could have a fracture and
pneumonia that's that's possible right
and so you have these these multiple
labels that are toggled on but very
rarely is one object multiple objects
it's not both a dog into cat right you
don't have cat dogs that are coming
around and so I think there there are
all of these technical challenges where
you can't just take off the shelf models
or tools algorithms that have been
developed because they're often
developed in a setting again for natural
images mostly where we don't have any of
these constraints and so there's been a
lot of work between the students and the
postdoc that Joseph and I are Co
supervising to try to understand how we
can modify a lot of these meta learning
few short learning zero shot learning
algorithms so that they work in this
setting yes I think what strikes me from
how you've described it is that co19
is an entirely new phenomenon that we
haven't seen before so the old models
you can't just apply them we have to
really think about again how do we
modify them for this particular
circumstance I think it's also it's
unclear for something like Ovid 19 right
how different it should be for example
in this one modality in chest x-rays
from pneumonia very severe pneumonia
right and so we know that in a lot of
early cases for example in China and
Iran
you would have coded 19 cases that were
diagnosed as just typical pneumonia
right which led to high mortality rates
initially and so it's unclear whether in
this one modality just looking at chest
x-rays without any additional
information
whether we would be able to detect a big
difference that you know just one
snapshot we're not seeing any
progression we're not seeing anything
else between an ammonia case and a Koba
19 case right and so that's why it's so
important that Joseph and his team have
been working to collect other indicators
along with just this image right so that
we can see for example maybe it's not a
one snapshot that you're given without
any context that's important maybe you
have to see some metadata I mean you
have to see some progression right and
so you know there's a there's a lot of
research there's a lot that we're going
to learn about kovat and its impact on
on people and your health hopefully
through this project so you guys have
both alluded to this a little but I want
to talk a little bit about the fact that
this is a new collaboration between your
two research groups so we've got a
research team at the vector Institute
supervised by Maria we've got a research
team at nila in Montreal supervised by
Joseph and you're you know you've you've
organized yourselves looking at
different objectives and different
projects tell us a little bit more about
the you know the team of people behind
the scenes that are really the front
lines doing you know the day-to-day
aspects of this research well I think we
have we have a bunch of students that
are specifically I guess a Carsten who's
who's between both teams right now so
he's a vector but where he used to be at
Neela so he's really fridging the gap
between these two groups so I think
that's that's it's good for both labs in
general to have that cross-pollination
are there medical student lung on down
who's um we were working on evaluating
Chester in some educational settings and
then we've shifted now to focus on on
how do we make this help treat the Kovac
cases right so in terms of figuring out
with the radiology and medical community
like that they want severity prediction
right and also looking at the
trajectories of patients so figure
isolating those specific cases have been
as been very I've been very has been
very useful and and I think it's a great
great
for people that we have working from
medical backgrounds to really look at
the computational side of all this and
how it can assist these things with some
collaborators at at Stony Brook students
they are working on on running these
tools that we're building to kind of
really analyze what they can do what
they can tell and inform these medical
professionals and how that's gonna
actually get into their clinical
workflow right at what point does a
decision to be made and their insights
into how that these - like if they can
span the gap in this this chasm between
the two fields right how how can that
workflow be disrupted by these medical
tools right so it's just like an
iterative process that has to keep going
and we need to make better tools better
but I think getting that feedback from
students that it's span this boundary is
is very important so critical when we're
computer scientists and used to you know
a certain way of working and a certain
way of thinking and a certain jargon to
work directly with the clinicians who
are at the front lines and you know they
know what tools and resources and
insights that they need you to help them
find out of the data but also really
helpful to hear from them with their
experiences and how AI can can really
help them in the course of their their
treatment of patients or is to tell us a
little bit about your team
so the team that I have here the way
that this sort of you know percolated is
I had a postdoc so insert postdoctoral
fellow who was working in my lab
previously and then I I had invited
Joseph to come and give a talk in in my
class so I have a machine learning for
Health graduate course that's taught in
the department of computer science and I
wanted him to come and give a lecture on
medical imaging and he came and the
students loved him they thought he did a
really fantastic job and so he and he
also had a chance to meet with some of
my students while he was visiting the
vector Institute and he had a chance to
meet with my postdoc and after he had
gone my postdoc Lola had said he's great
you know
like it was really helpful chatting with
him and so she and I had been talking
outside of the context of Kovac
completely independently before this all
hit we had a project where we were
looking at and this paper is posted to
archive so we're looking at the
differences in classification rates in
chest x-ray images amongst people of
different ethnicities different genders
in the United States of different
insurance types and so there's a lot of
exclusion and there's a lot of
difference in how accurate machine
learning models are when you train
state-of-the-art models and how accurate
they are in classifying people of
different again genders ethnicities and
insurance types on these standard tasks
and some of this is just because we have
under representation right of these data
in these data sets that's the way that
it is and so she and I had had done this
project previously which is currently
under review but also posted on archives
if people want to read it and then as
she had spoken to Joseph about this and
we were talking about ways to fix this
right so you know we've established that
there is this problem we'd really like
to fix it and so then the kovat happens
and we discussed with Joseph you know
really what we want to fix is this
classification problem wouldn't it be
nice if we were thinking about it in
this robustness sense right not just
from a bias perspective but just from
overall robustness and so she's led a
lot of this on my team side and then
Joseph and I talked about how we really
and so Joseph has been you know on all
our weekly team calls for a month and a
half now right like going through all
the planning for this project but then
Joseph and I had discussed you know we
wanted to have an additional student
right somebody who really could do the
extra bridging because Lola was sort of
you know part of my team previously and
Joseph has some students who are part of
his team previously so we wanted this
additional person who could help with
the bridging and that is this student
Carsten who's fantastic and we've been
meeting with for the past two weeks so
this is onboarding and I think it's it
is really important to have a mixture of
people from both sides
so both people who you know have
experience in different kinds of machine
learning experience in on the clinical
side in trying to understand how you
might scrape things best how you might
label things best when there's a
discrepancy between different sources of
information which one you should rely
upon more so I think that that has been
very helpful that's so great and I love
the idea of you know having somebody who
bridges both teens and these times when
we can't meet face to face and we have
to meet virtually having somebody who's
going back and forth and interacting and
really seeing both sides of the project
very deeply it's so helpful to sort of
keep everybody together okay so we're
gonna move to some audience questions
now and I've got a good one here that's
come in and so it reads Joseph mentioned
that a clear licensing policy is helpful
when attempting to use a publicly
available image data set could you speak
a bit more about the features of a good
licensing policy what challenges do you
face with licensing policies yeah so
with a lot of data sets there are very
ambiguous licenses that they that they
have so for a subset of the data set we
have that's come from Euro rad and in
radio PDA which I really want to shout
out to their their groups because that
their licensing is a Creative Commons
non-commercial share-alike license which
is just great for that people want to
contribute to do public research right
so a non-commercial license makes that
makes everyone happy with that
arrangement right because if this
commercial interest this can make people
more hesitant to share so having that
non-commercial license is fine for for
doing research right um and then there's
been a new data release that came over
from Hanover University in Germany this
is that just like a few days ago and we
just we just discussed with them and
they want to contribute their data to
merge it into our data set it there
they're gonna continually do data
releases and they did like a creative
commons share-alike i think yeah so it's
just a creative commons share-alike
there's no non-commercial restrictions
it's not even more open than the
existing data we had which which is
which is
really great so I think it just makes it
easy to do anything with this data set I
mean I think that that's really an
enabling license right so the licenses
are more for the enabling aspect of it
and then for the epitome of open
datasets
there's the NIH data set which we can
all like run on summers 2017 kind of
completely like broke up in the entire
field of digital Rai radiology right
with this data set that had a it's like
a public domain license so this note
there's no that it's very clear what you
can do with it you can do anything right
and this has enabled us to make
derivatives of it and really like Google
has built a new data set which is based
on that data set and they just relabeled
it and then release that as a derivative
work and this is a this has been a it's
really it's a high highly act like
highly accurate really specialized data
set so like these derivative works are
the result of a really good clear
license right that it makes everyone
happy with that situation if the more
confident that they're not gonna have to
take down this derivative work after
they released it right and we can
already see that happening with the data
set that we've released right given the
ability for groups to add annotations on
top and then release that as a
subsequent work right so we've had a
group that that's annotated a lot of
lung regions thanks bounding boxes and
released that with the width so we it's
now in our repository released alongside
our data so they've kind of labeled a
subset we're in discussion with with
other people that are going to do even
more fine-grain segmentations on the
data we have right and I think that
they're doing that because this data is
open in the first place right so I think
that it fed that so the clear licensing
makes it easy for everyone to work with
and use for their different purposes
right yeah I mean we we know how
critical data is the foundation of what
we do in AI we couldn't do any of this
without large very accessible very good
datasets so so important to have access
to them
and I love what you just described
Joseph about how the fact that they're
open means that other people are doing
more and bigger and other
interesting things with them and in fact
it becomes a global collaboration when
we're thinking about how other people
are making derivatives and adding on to
the work that you're doing it really
makes a very strong case for continuing
around open science ok so we have
another question that's come in Murray
had one question that came in from the
audience was there there wondering if
there are any applications on your AI
based approach that can help to inform
the development of new treatments for
copa90 I think it's it's hard to know
what this could be extended to in terms
of treatments one of the things that has
been really hard to hear from a lot of
the local hospital specialists that I
collaborate with on other projects but
are now sort of overwhelmed with Coppa
19 treatment is that many of our most
intensive treatments are not working
consistently right so there's been a lot
of anecdotal reports but now several
reports coming out of other locations
that were hit much harder right so this
is out of China out of Italy out of Iran
out of New York that mechanical
ventilation is is not working
consistently and that some of the
pre-existing conditions that you might
have assumed would have led to really
really poor responses some comorbidities
like asthma they are not right and so I
think that it's possible that a better
detector a better classifier for early
screening especially as we start to have
conversations in North America about
opening up what that means for summer
what that means for the fall weather
there will be second waves that come in
I think it opens up the ability to have
more maybe quicker screaming or more
physically distant screening lower cost
screening for particular populations so
I think it could lead to a better
understanding and characterization I
think there's a lot of very good work on
the biochemistry side being led by
people like
marceline MIT or a la Asperger guzik
here at University of Toronto who are
trying to figure out exactly what's
happening with specific drugs or
treatments great thanks for that we have
time for just one more question reading
lots of questions coming in from the
audience so lots of interest in this
topic in this project
one more question maybe for the both of
you how do you balance the need for
fast-growing research and pre print
publication with the rigor and peer
review during the pandemic right so we
we want to get our results that we want
to share with the world but it's you
know it's not the same thing as a
peer-reviewed publication so how do you
balance that guys so so I think nothing
should change because why were we not
being critical about the papers in the
past we just blindly trusted the
peer-review right yeah so I think if a
paper is is hard to understand and
therefore and for that reason you can't
like believe that it's right because you
don't understand the entire experimental
protocol then don't trust the paper
right like well why should peer-review
allow someone else to tell you you
should trust that just more work to
filter these papers yourselves you
should always be doing this with every
paper that so how important is it right
now to get your results out in the in
the preprint world I think it's becoming
increasingly apparent that the the style
of early release of results that is I
should say in different academic
communities have very different ways
that they tend to push results out and
the machine learning community for a
while now has had a culture of
publishing a preprint on a service like
archive and then as it is undergoing
peer review and then you may see for
example this is common I just want to
emphasize how common this is that a
paper is posted in September of 2018 on
archive it is submitted somewhere and
doesn't make it into that particular
machine learning conference right unlike
many of the journals where there's this
you know year-long back-and-forth where
well edit this site this add this you
have this one shot that
you know mildly stochastic rate depends
on what reviewers you get you often
don't have a rebuttal in some of these
conferences and so you might submit to
nerves and it doesn't get into nerves
and so that's fine you know we say like
reroll right you you submit essentially
the same paper with some Corrections or
clarifications as recommended by the
reviewers to ICML or to if it's more
data science or focus to kdd to you know
wherever you're submitting it to right
so I don't think that culture should
change I'm happy that other publishing
cultures are coming more in line with
that I think that that puts
significantly more a much higher
expectation of rigor on the pie so my
students one of my my previous students
really wanted to archive their work
because they felt some pressure and I
told the student it's not ready and they
said why it's not peer reviewed it's
just archive and I said no like this is
the ready to go yeah it has to be ready
to go this has to pass my sniff test
because it has our names on it and it
means that we are putting this out there
for consumption and you don't want to
mislead people and so I think that it
shifts the burden from a well let's just
throw this out to peer review we'll see
if they spot a mistake just saying like
this is an academic product that I am
approving as I think this is good enough
to go out there thank you so much to
both of you for sharing your insights on
on your project and also the inner
workings of the machine learning
community academic research publishing
community we are over time I have to
apologize to our audience for going a
little bit over time but the
conversation was so interesting I wanted
to let everybody know that this is a
series that the CFR is offering and we
have another is coming up on June 4th
with a fellow in our humans in the micro
pot humans in the microbiome program his
name is Professor Hendrick pointer he's
from McMaster University and he's going
to talk about what makes this pan divot
he's an evolutionary geneticist I'm
gonna talk about what makes this
pandemic difference and what we can
learn from past pandemics to inform us
about what we know about : 19 so it
should be very interesting
and we hope that you can join us then so
please visit our websites c4 RCA to find
out more about the upcoming webinars
we'll have the video for this one posted
next week and we'll look forward to
seeing you again thanks once more to
Marcia and Joseph bye bye
you